i am your family
give me your hand she would not get away
from me
that jay irate at his cousin yesterday
around 3 a.m outside a club in downtown
l.a seconds before kanye allegedly
punched this autographed seeker knocking
him to the ground
why did he just do that i'll just tell
you that blue covenant mask didn't stop
that knockout
in an interview with hollywood unlocks
jason lee yay defends his actions it's 3
a.m in front of the warehouse
i'm saying you don't know what i'm
dealing with right now this dude is just
he just had this like real attitude like
what you going to do this was a person
who was chasing him down to get
autographs he was really frustrated with
the narrative that
was being painted about him he said i
just want to get in control of my own
narrative for once give me your hand hey
go ahead no no you were supposed to talk
to her the her kanye's referring to
ex-kim kay yay claims she had security
stop him from visiting daughter north at
school so he asked his cousin to deliver
this message to kim security ain't gonna
be in between me and my children
and
my children going to be on tick-tock
without my permission but he also seemed
angered over kim's new relationship and
allegedly recorded this leaked diss
track
how are you going to bring me to snl and
kiss the dude you dating right in front
of me and everybody's like oh that's
that's cool and i'm hearing that the new
boyfriend is actually in the house that
i can't
even go to he's bothered by not being
able to have access to his children the
way that he did before
the lapd tells e.t they are
investigating yay for alleged battery if
convicted he could face a maximum of six
months in jail as for his claims about
kim a source tells e.t she has never
denied kanye from seeing his children
he directly addressed the kardashians in
the video he's going to fight them with
everything legally and he's going to do
it very commonly don't play
for my children and it's going to be all
legal it's gonna be all legal baby